ohne boot gab es auf dieser
schnellstraße kein entkommen für
eingeschlossene autofahrer starkregen
hat die tunnelröhren fast komplett
gefüllt ob es unter wasser opfer gibt
die es nicht wie er zurück ans ufer
geschafft haben ist offen
die feuerwehr taucher durchsuchen da
unten ein umgekipptes fahrzeug da könnte
jemand drin sein
aber ich weiß es nicht um solche
suchaktionen möglichst zu verhindern
gilt eine eindringliche warnung der
behörden lasst eure autos stehen die
menschen in los alcazar es neben
eigentlich am wasser doch manche nun
sogar mittendrin nicht weit entfernt von
den mittelmeerstränden schiebt sich
braunes regenwasser durch die straßen
und der blick in richtung himmel
verspricht kaum besserung dauerregen und
starke gewitter werden auch das
wochenende dominieren das ungewöhnliche
unwetter gebilde dreht sich konstant
über dem südosten spaniens 200 liter
regen pro quadratmeter in 24 stunden 120
allein in den letzten sechs stunden so
was gibt es nur alle 100 jahre sagen wir
die wetterexperten etwas treibgut dann
richtig viel treibgut und bald wird die
nächste brücke so unfreiwillig zum
staudamm eilig her beorderte bagger und
lastwagen versuchen das nötigste zu
beseitigen der katastrophenschutz kommt
kaum zur ruhe
oberste priorität hat die suche nach
vermissten erst danach kann das
riesenprojekt aufräumen so richtig
beginnen